[Musica]
era l'11 ottobre del 2019 mi trovavo
nella sala prove coro al terzo piano del
Teatro alla Scala
ero nel periodo finale del mio intenso
all'accademia e quel pomeriggio ero lì
per il mio ultimo incontro con lui
saprandina la prima Arpa della Scala
è stato allora che le ho confidato le
incertezze sul mio futuro avevo appena
concluso tutti i miei studi e mi trovavo
in quel classico momento della vita in
cui ti senti perso
io non sapevo se intraprendere o meno un
percorso faticoso e rischioso che però
se avesse avuto successo avrebbe
realizzato il mio sogno
vi starete chiedendo di che segno si
tratta
uno dei sogni più ambiti per un giovane
musicista e quello di vincere una tra le
competizioni più importanti al mondo per
il proprio strumento e nel mio caso era
l'international Art contest in Israel
che senso hanno questi concorsi
Ebbene per molti musicisti sono la sola
possibilità che hanno per ottenere
grandi visibilità sono quindi un mezzo
per compiere in grande stile la missione
della musica e dell'arte che è quella di
comunicare e esprimere emozioni
comunicare trasmetteremo fino alla gente
e con grande stile Intendo per il più
ampio pubblico possibile
un bel sogno quindi Ma come potevo
prevedere come sarebbe andata a finire
in quel periodo stavo attraversando una
fase particolarmente buia della mia vita
sotto tanti punti di vista e poi la mia
mente mi riportava quando qualche anno
fa ho partecipato a un altro grande
concorso e mi sono classificata in
semifinale Beh ho visto svanire il mio
obiettivo dopo aver investito tutte le
mie energie il mio tempo dopo aver
rinunciato a tanto e ora si trattava di
affrontare tutto ciò per una seconda
volta significava rimettermi in
discussione ma soprattutto avrebbe
significato una vera e propria sfida con
me stessa
ma ritorniamo a quel pomeriggio al
teatro La Scala
È qui che lui siamo incoraggia a provare
il concorso in Israele Senza riserve
nonostante fossi già in ritardo di un
anno dalla data di uscita del repertorio
così trascorrono giorni settimane di
riflessione
Finché prendo la decisione di tornare
nella mia terra la Puglia dopo cinque
anni vissuti tra Bruxelles Londra e
Milano
siamo a febbraio 2020
e io decido di iniziare la dura
preparazione per Israele
ora non starò qui a raccontarvi tutti i
dettagli del lungo processo di
preparazione nei tanti imprevisti sorti
durante i mesi di lockdown perché potrei
continuare fino a notte fonda vi dirò
solamente che in quel periodo non si
potevano fare concerti
e questo è indispensabile per poter
essere pronti ad affrontare un concorso
di questo livello
arriviamo quindi a marzo 2022 48 ore
prima di partire per Tel Aviv tutto è
pronto Se non Ok inizio a non sentirmi
tanto bene
avevo qualche decimo di febbre panico mi
sarebbe stata categoricamente negata la
partenza e avrei letteralmente sprecato
due anni della mia vita
quindi faccio immediatamente un test
rapido Sono stati 15 minuti più lunghi
della mia vita in attesa del risultato
negativo così come negativi sono stati
anche i tamponi molecolari obbligatori
per il viaggio
Per fortuna si è trattato di un falso
allarme Io sono di nuovo in forma e
finalmente in Israele
lì i giorni trascorrono intense
frenetici sono giorni di concentrazione
ma anche di agitazione
Finché mi ritrovo il quarto round la
tanto agognata finale
in programma C'è il meraviglioso
concerto per arpa e orchestra di Claire
le altre due finaliste mi raccontano di
averlo già suonato in orchestra Per me
invece non era stato così avevo avuto la
possibilità di provare solo il primo
movimento in orchestra ma mai il
concerto per intero e ora l'avrei fatto
Non solo per la giuria e il pubblico in
sala ma anche per chiunque da ogni parte
del mondo seguisse la diretta streaming
La serata inizia e quando arriva il mio
turno l'adrenalina e alle stelle
Salgo sul palco e il direttore
dell'attacco e la musica inizia
stavo finalmente vivendo gli ottimi più
temuti ma allo stesso tempo più
desiderati da anni
nel momento in cui poi tutto tace Eccoci
alle estenuante attesa dei risultati
terzo posto
non sono io e la tensione sale
secondo posto
non sono io e io che penso e se non
assegnano il primo premio a volte accade
primo posto
mi è stato chiesto più volte cosa abbia
provato in quel momento
semplicemente non riuscivo a credere che
fosse successo proprio a me
questo non è stato solo il felice
risultato di due anni di studio ma di
anni e anni di duro lavoro di sacrifici
economici di Arduo scelte fin da quando
a otto anni ho toccato l'arpa per la
prima volta
dopo che i miei genitori non musicisti
mi portarono a sentire il concerto che
mi ha cambiato la vita
durante i mesi di preparazione ho dovuto
fare i conti con i miei demoni interiori
quelli che mi riportavano al concorso
precedente quelli che mi dicevano non ce
la farai i sogni sono solo illusioni
quelli che incupivano tutte le mie
giornate
perché ci ho provato
Forse per una promessa fatta a chi da
tempo vi viene mi ricordi
O forse perché la speranza e la voglia
di farcela sono state più forti della
paura
e ora mi rivolgo a tutti voi
se avete un sogno professionale un
progetto di vita un qualcosa di
importante che mi sembra impossibile da
realizzare per qualsiasi motivo
e solo attraversando l'oceano di
complessità questo oscuro Limbo fatto di
solitudine di dubbi incertezze eventi
contrari
che riuscirete a fare grandi cose
sempre a condizione
che abbiate il Folle coraggio di non
arrendervi mai
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]